[Music]
as we said you are from chicago and uh
you wanted to give a gift to the people
of chicago that was important to you yes
absolutely as i said i love it here
so uh you know it saddens me that there
are two groups of chicagoans who just
vehemently hate one another
uh
cubs fans and white sox fans so
let's get this straight i've heard
there's a
yeah it's legendary and and and you
never know uh you know when you're in a
room and you bring up one team you never
know what reaction you're going to get
it seems like this is just a terrible
feud and your dream
well if i may i i would like to to try
to broker a peace treaty between the two
groups of fans if we bring them together
yeah if we could get a cubs fan out here
and a white sox fan
[Applause]
okay no you're gonna bring these guys
together well
i'm gonna try to bridge this gap between
these two chicago fans
by uh bringing out
someone who they both equally hate uh
saint louis cardinals fans
[Applause]
[Music]
gentlemen ready to do this what's going
on
did i win something yeah you did
[Music]
saddest thing i've ever heard
before a beating is did i win something